welcome to this video playing a slim jim
for 389 and it's going to be Kings
Indian know some in tycoon crowd let's
hope for that mistake okay didn't happen
between 93 Queen c3 is very nice for
white but people really fell into that
fall into that trap anymore
yeah it's very similar to gruene fat
white tries to maintain the center try
with e3 a lot with e for want to make
this solid build up he can win some
tempe with bishop you six oh wait i
can't ago g5 actually might might be am
i can do a five I think oh it still does
that oh and 45 why not why is the five
not a movie ever poor don't do this to
me at five Bishop c3b takes you three
the piece takes you four wins apiece
just a pin and d 595 I Queen B 5 or just
a piece what is the point
check write a five this also on Queen
before I mean what's Knight e5 happening
here okay so i also have f1 i also have
a phone so quincy three takes on then
evil will win the peace or is there
something better I don't think so
I just wonder if he takes with the a paw
over the a night yeah do I have
something better here when you fall and
I got happen to be four is pretty good
it's been the peas and ask questions
later
seeking out a night a four or something
don't tell me this this works and I did
what I don't think so ok this is also in
the mixer it's a whole group now
black resigns yep so that was not
working there should be six it's kind of
normal in this this type of position but
it does just doesn't work here I mean I
think that's just d5 and that's it Jay
thank you it's really not much more to
save it just does win he has to play him
I mean we can always flick this end
let's just make some sense and then
engine says 85 the other dentists make
quite some sense with a fork coming it's
just a normal position here I mean me
being the classical player that I am I
rather be white but it's not nothing
special so gruenfelder type of position
yeah and it's not working it's a case
where I mean he had to expect that move
I mean or calculate that move and maybe
he wasn't he was thinking of this and
here he thought I would take like this
maybe and he didn't see that this is so
in the position as well as well okay
well thanks for watching